hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
I've been really into a few pairs of
headphones recently I'm getting more
into the audio game and also by getting
into this audio stuff I've found that a
lot of people never really get to listen
to their music on anything other than
the earbuds that come with their phone
may be the classic earbuds that come
with the iPhone and that's fine for a
lot of people but once you first listen
to a actual decent pair of good
headphones you'll never want to go back
to those old iPhone earbuds probably
ever again
plus it's you know it's about to be the
back school season so why not everyone's
got a budget maybe you want to get a new
sweet pair of headphones to go with your
new back-to-school laptop this is why
I'm making this video this is without
any further ado the top 5 headphones on
my list for under 200 bucks number five
is the Bayer dynamic custom one pros now
these are really likable headphones and
they're actually a great introductory
set of headphones to anyone who's
getting their first nice pair I would
say that pretty much all of it is
likable I'd say it's very comfortable
they actually sound pretty good and
actually really good-looking headphones
for once a lot of these headphones
aren't the best looking but you can
actually customize the actual side
plates to get a different sort of
pattern or color look if you want so
those are nice and the real custom
feature that sticks out about the custom
one pros is the tunable bass port so if
you're used to a more bass heavy booming
sound you can open up the bass port on
the bottom of the headphones and get
that time of sound if you don't like all
that basing you want a more high-end mid
friendly sound you can close up the bass
port and get that sound too so that's
pretty much the only pair of headphones
that I recommend that actually has this
feature and it's definitely under 200
bucks which is really nice number four
is the grotto SR 80 eyes now one could
argue that the grotto SR 225 eyes would
probably be better because they're I
guess exactly $200 right now but the SR
80 is I would say are a steal for the
price you can get them at they're often
under $100 right now and the reason
these are so good as these are the
perfect introductory pair of headphones
for open back design a lot of the
headphones you see out there most of
them probably 90% are closed back
headphones and that's by design a lot of
them are like that but these open-back
headphones are designed more for studio
use they leak a lot more obviously but
they give you that
room sound it's very cool that we get to
hear the instruments as if they're
literally positioned around the room
with you it's almost like you're sitting
next to the artist that's singing it's
really cool and you can just snap along
the beat and you hear yourself snapping
just fine something you can't hear and a
noise cancelling or close back prayer
headphones so the SR ad is are a great
introductory pair of headphones for the
open back design and I'd recommend them
at their price they're really good
number three is the v-moda crossfade LPS
now these are already a very popular
pair of headphones a lot of people
already love them if you check out the
reviews you'll see they're pretty much
all glowingly positive what's nice about
these is first of all they come in a
bunch of different colors there's a
black as a silver there's a white
there's a I think a purple version as
well there's a bunch of different ways
you can get this done and what's also
nice is these are a very comfortable
pair of headphones so you'll see again
with all the very popular reviews about
this that these are really comfortable
easy to get used to nice to put on
doesn't weigh too much so it doesn't
clamp your ears down for too long
they're very nice headphones and they're
very popular so if you ask anyone who's
used these headphones what they think
about them they'll probably recommend
the minutes on a heartbeat over anything
else they've tried there is also now a
version 2 of the crossfade LPS and I
haven't listened to them yet so I can't
really determine if it's just another
version just to make more money for them
but I do know that the originals are
pretty much trustworthy they sound great
can't go wrong so the number two and the
number one on my list are the only pairs
that I use pretty much daily on a daily
basis there are also very different
types of headphones for very different
purposes my number two right here is the
j-bird blue buds ex I cannot get enough
of these headphones first of all you can
get either a black or a white design so
you can get all black stealth black
looks really cool
or you can get this design which I ended
up going with by myself which is the
black and white sort of a stormtrooper
look and there are a completely wireless
earbuds they're wireless you can put
them on they can basically hook around
the back of your neck plug them in and
you're good to go and they connect to
your device via bluetooth so your iPod
your mp3 player your phone turn on
Bluetooth pair it up and you're getting
high quality music immediately what's
nice about these is they're they're
wireless so you wouldn't expect them to
last that long on battery and as you can
see you can't even tell where the
battery is honestly to be honest the
battery is actually
in one of the earbuds here but these
last seven eight nine hours on a single
charge and actually charged by just
opening up the back here and plugging it
in via a USB they're really well built
they last a long time on a charge and
they sound phenomenal they sound
incredible I don't really ever leave the
house without these like any time I'm
walking to the train walking to class
walking back from the train I always
have the blue buds ex they're just that
convenient they're small compact
portable can't really ask for much else
they also come with a lot of accessories
where you can put them in your ear and
they will basically never fall out so
you can run around I can't actually hear
myself not because they seal so well but
they never fall out of your ear you can
run around with them like I do you can
practice with them on I love these and I
would recommend everyone at least have
some pair of wireless headphones it's
one of those things where once you get
wireless earbuds you never really want
to go back and this is such a good
experience that I recommend these in a
heartbeat try them at least they're
incredible they're also the only pair of
headphones on this list that you can
wear with Google glass though I wouldn't
recommend it because they'll go out
looking a little bit like a cyborg with
all this stuff on your head but honestly
it's possible and I can't say that about
any of the other pairs of headphones
I've recommended but it's definitely a
thing to consider just how portable you
guys are so this leaves are number one
which you've probably all predicted by
now if you've watched the rest of my
videos it's the audio technica ath M 50s
these are my go-to headphones for sound
quality period now III do have a budget
for audio equipment and I could spend
four or five hundred dollars on
headphones but this there's a there's a
point of diminishing return I don't use
an amp with these headphones I just plug
and go and get incredible quality and
the m50 s are really trustworthy if I
want a flat accurate sound if I want to
know what I'm getting when a monitoring
audio for maybe my camera or from a
microphone I go for the m50 s by default
I also listen to these a lot on an
airplane because even though they're not
exactly noise cancelling they have a
great seal now these are the red and
black version of them I also have the
all-black version and if you want to see
the review of the white version there's
a TLD today video where he goes over
them but they're also a pretty stylish
looking pair of headphones especially in
the all-black they look pretty good and
they just go right over the year and
they're also I can't recommend these
guys enough honestly if you go to my
original review video which is maybe a
little embarrassing because it's an
older video but if you check that video
out in the description below you'll see
just how much I love these and I can't
find any flaws about these headphones
there they're like they take every
single mark where they're comfortable
they look good they sound great they're
priced well they're built well
everything about them takes every box
and they're priced like a hundred and
ninety bucks or less all the time so
I'll have the links to purchase all the
things that I talked about in this video
below and if I've reviewed the
headphones that I talked about I will
also put a link right below that like
button for you guys to check them out
but at the end of the day this is the
number one pair of headphones that I
recommend to basically anyone who asks
me what kind of headphones they should
buy but again the rest of the top five
that doesn't mean they're bad that means
they just weren't quite as incredible as
these again the jaybird bluebloods x2 if
you're going to get earbuds at all
please get those just do it they're
really good I also just forgot to
mention you can fold these up so they
take the portable check mark to I'm done
also some honorable mention the clip s4
series they're actually good they're
good earbuds and they're actually really
really cheap so if you want to get a
really cheap beginner starting pair of
earbuds that are better than the ones
that came with your iPod or iPhone clips
s4s sony xbar a crowd favorite people
love them because of the way they sound
and the comfort holy crap they're
comfortable I've worn them for a little
bit I don't actually own a pair but I
can vouch for the fact that they're just
pillowy soft and really lightweight the
band up top is really light and they're
incredibly just really comfortable I
love wearing Denon or Dean on don't know
how to pronounce it but they have some
also really great headphones now these
might not always fall under the $200 mic
or I understand but I'll leave a link
below so you can check out their site
where they do have some really high
quality stuff there and of course beats
by dre also makes some no no they don't
sorry they don't make any good
headphones for under 200 bucks anyway
thank you for watching this video quick
just top 5 video going over my top 5
favorite headphones for under 200 bucks
thank you for watching be sure to
subscribe if you want to watch more
videos that I make in the future and of
course
like button if you enjoy talk to the
next one pace
you